how are you doing sir
i'm good and i'm already jealous of your
toys but i'm sure you get that luck
that's what i put them up for it's
literally for you anthony ramos i think
is literally fighting one of those
transformers as we speak right now
[Music]
first i want to start by saying how much
i want to thank you for giving me your
time this morning i know that your time
is precious
i just want to say thank you um so
before we jump into in the heights which
i absolutely
loved uh i've been asking a lot of
people during the pandemic
a few of the same first questions and i
would like to ask you those as well
uh what tv series would you love to
guest star on
i guess daron oh i thought you're gonna
say was i watching
um the the show we watched the most
during the pandemic was
bluey um because it is the only kids
show
that like the whole family can be
hysterically laughing at but i wouldn't
dare
guest star on it um you do you need to
be australian to be on that show
um so uh guest star
i have no idea i'm sorry i also want to
know your tv
and you don't want me on uh blow up
because i would break all the glass
uh what movie or movies do you think
you've seen the most
oh that's a good question um during the
pandemic
it doesn't even have to be during the
doesn't have to be during the pandemic
oh like just full stop in general yeah
um
i there's certain movies that if i
switching channels and they're on i just
dropped the
like the remote and sit down godfather
and godfather two are among those movies
um i i watch seven samurai once a year
i always try to rope someone else into
it i actually roped my
14 and six year old nephews into it and
and that was a joy i was like
this movie's three hours long it's in
japanese it's black and white
but i swear it's one of the best movies
ever made like stick
with me and uh and they loved it um
and um but again like i i honestly think
it's
probably like lion king because
my i watched it a lot when i was a kid
and my kids
like can't get enough i asked this
question of a lot of people and i think
you might be
an anomaly that this might not apply to
you if you could get the financing for
any project tomorrow
what would you make and why i think
there's a lot of people that want to get
in business with you which is why i
don't know if
this question applies to you um
i will um
i can't tell you i can't tell you i
literally can't tell you because i'm
thinking of one specifically and i'm
working on it
that's what i was saying i think that
people want to line up to
be in business with you uh which is
amazing they don't always want to line
up but
it's uh but i'm working on it completely
uh
i loved howard ashman's work i think he
was a genius
and um i find it interesting that he
worked on the
in the theater created these great
things and then went over to disney
and had his hand in bringing back
animation and his work is
iconic have you ever realized or thought
about the fact that
you theater and then all of a sudden
you're working in animation
bringing your voice to all these
animated projects and it's it's a
similar
i don't want to say it's you know
obviously you never had the success that
you had on
broadway but it's interesting you guys
are walking a similar path
well yeah i mean first of all i think
that howard ashman is as responsible for
me talking to you as
anyone in my life uh little mermaid was
the first time i felt truly transported
uh in the movies um i just read that sam
right passed i'm heartbroken i never got
to meet him uh before he passed um
because
i i spent fourth grade jumping on my
desk
and singing under the sea um but but the
other
really big lesson in howard ashman's
work was that
he brought not just his incredible lyric
writing
um and and alan menken's incredible
songwriting but his sense of musical
structure
and his and his and his incredible
storytelling sense and that has been a
model
not just for me but for bobby and
kristin lopez
uh and and for so many folks uh for benj
and justin
um who got to work on the the new
aladdin um i'll never forget
the first table read i sat for moana
someone sort of turned around and said
to me like don't forget to raise your
hand
because like we all are gonna be
doodling and we know what we do but we
don't do what you do
so like raise your hand and tell us what
musicals can do in this space that we
don't know
um and that was incredibly empowering uh
to me
and and it's been a joy working on vivo
and working on encanto at disney in
particular because
i'm the guy that raises my hand and says
i can do that in a song
or i can you know like we can have those
characters sing to each other you don't
need three scenes about it
um again like that's the real legacy of
howard ashman
i think to me is that he brought um
he brought so many of the incredible
like music
musical theater techniques to to
animated film
yeah i i for people that don't know who
he is my god research
yeah yeah he's he's beyond genius um
so uh my last thing before getting in uh
into in the heights
uh there's rumors that you and weird al
are working on this
new thing for hall of presidents at
disneyland
is that is that true or is it not true
that
is not true don't a
i actually just called him last week
because that great time story about him
uh like got put in audio form and i was
just like
i read this article and i'm going to
listen to it now i love you al goodbye
jumping into the reason i get to talk to
you today and again in the heights i
cannot recommend
this film enough uh but i want to go
backwards originally kenny ortega was
going to helm this
back when it first got acquired it was
going to be universal
at that point would you have reprised
your role
if kenny had made the film yeah yeah
that was the plan um and um
and kenny is wonderful and kenny is is
still a good friend
uh but we got stuck in like the old
hollywood way of thinking the hopefully
old hollywood way of thinking which was
it went from
we'll do anything to make this movie to
if this
international music star isn't
in this role we can't make the movie
because you there are no latino stars
who test
international now listen there were no
latino stars in in the heights when we
opened on broadway and no one had ever
heard of me and kiara and no one had
ever heard of our actors our our
creative team
um so we didn't think that would be a
barrier at the time but again
um i it was it was sort of the lie
that becomes a self-perpetuating thing
like if you don't give
latino actors the shots in those roles
you don't make
international stars and one of the
things that
john did so brilliantly with crazy rich
asians
was he stacked the deck um he stacked
the deck with
asian and asian-american stars that you
know very well
um and and folks who are absolutely
stars and what he did was actually
create a lane
create lanes where none existed with
that film and now gemma chan is going to
be in a marvel movie
and now henry goldberg is snake eyes um
like that's unbelievable they're movie
stars and they always were
they just didn't get the at-bat uh and
and that's my hope
for for in the heights is you know i
mean i i think i already joked to you
that like
anthony's in a transformers movie um
and um and i hope that for leslie and i
hope you know like i hope that we make
this lane and sort of forever give a lie
to
let's not take chances on young latino
talent they don't
test international we're 32 countries i
think we'll be okay
yeah i i fully agree with everything you
just said um
can you describe though how did kenny's
vision
compared to what john brought to the
screen was it
similar at all was it radically
different it was it was apples to
oranges because it was it was a
different time
um the screenplay did not have the
updates that this current screenplay had
it was much closer to the original
uh show um you know kenny is an
amazing director an amazing musical
director
so that'll always be a what if uh
in my head um but again like the time
and the distance kiara had to update the
script
uh could not have happened if that movie
version had gone through like i'm very
like
zen it happens for a reason about it
because
the you know so many of the updates that
kiara thought of
uh to really smartly update this for now
uh wouldn't have existed in that version
so um
you know and then john's big pitch um
which we never had the clout to do at
the in the
in the other version was um these are
everyday folks but they have
huge dreams um you know we were never
given the permission to fully shoot on
location
in that other version and to you know
film an esther williams number at the
high bridge pool
uh which exists on 175th street to film
passenger fe
in the one street tunnel those weren't
on the table because the budget
constraints were what they were
uh in the previous version so um john
uh really like sort of had the vision
and the clout to be able to
get these characters to dream as big as
possible and put that on screen
i think one of the the reasons this film
worked so well for me
was the filming on location that just
added
so much to it just brought everything
alive
um what i have to ask you is what was it
like for you watching this finished film
for the first time
and i know it's a kind of a weird like
i'm sure you loved it but like
it it had to be just so amazing to watch
this
because it's so good and i can't i'm
just curious what you thought
yeah there's it's very hard to answer
this question without crying so i
apologize in advance
um but the there was there were layers
to it right like there's the location
scout
where you're walking john through the
neighborhood you've spent your life in
and you go oh well my my wife and i on
our first date
walked through here um and then suddenly
we're
filming when you're home there uh
there's
the 190th street tunnel where paciencia
fe
happens and abuela claudia sings and
that was the tunnel i traversed to visit
my abuela because my abuela in the last
years of her life was in an elderly
nursing home on 190th
and autobahn on the other side of the
island and i would go through that
tunnel say the elevator up
so that abuela sings her song with it
like
again and again the entire score is a
love letter
to this neighborhood so to film it on
location
um was just unbelievable and then the
part that i can't talk about without
crying is
the way in which we were embraced by the
neighborhood the fact that we
set up shop on 175th street and we cast
as many local extras as we could and we
got costume elements from the local
stores and we
you know our catering was local and like
like every aspect of it we just tried to
be good neighbors
while we were there and um it was
it was an incredible summer and then
when i watch it i just
i can't believe it was real like i can't
believe like i would film these songs
with the hydrants open and i would walk
home
like it's never gonna happen to me again
um so
it was it was um i'll tell you that when
they first started rehearsing when
you're home
um i didn't know it was gonna be in j
hood wright park
i walked my son to preschool through
that park
um and when i picked him up i brought
him to rehearsal and i called my wife
and said
i know you're working but you should get
over here and she
she she came down from our apartment to
look at the rehearsal
and she just looks up and goes that's my
grandmother's building
excuse my grandmother's building is
going to be in this movie like
i mean the layers to this [ __ ] it's just
you know
it's because it's also a place where
we've spent our lives so it's not just
the
the creative journey it's our it's our
life journey is reflected in us
i'm almost out of time i want to bullet
hit you with a few other things because
i man i have so much i want to ask you
about uh do you think
that a hamil i have to ask you the
hamilton movie question but i'm curious
due to the popularity of the stage
production all around the world
and the money that it generates does
that impact
sort of people's desire to make a movie
out of it because there's so much money
with the production
and how much it's generating or does
that not impact it at all
i don't know whether it's money or not
but i feel like uh
i got a golden ticket because tommy
actually made
the stage production a satisfying movie
theatrical experience you know
it's very old school to put an
intermission in a movie
um but you know fiddler on the roof did
that like there are movies that older
musicals that did that
um so i i mean for me it's not so much
that there's uh
less desire because i get asked the
question by every film interviewer that
interviews me
but um like do we need it and what is
the directorial vision behind it because
when it comes to adaptations like it's
really hard to adapt to musicals
like what stays in what goes when you
have a movie that has all the songs in
it
um so you know it's gonna take a
director with like a really
clear and strong vision um to
to don't you what yeah
john's now busy with he's in wicked
lands now
really exciting um you know wicked is
where
when i was working on in the heights
lackamore uh my music director was the
only one with a real job
in the business and he was conducting
wicket so we would sit in the pit
and like that was my first time in an
orchestra pit um so
the fact that there's a weird full
circle thing about that john is now
tackling that next
i have to wrap i'm just going to say i
cannot wait to see what you've done with
jonathan's work with tick tick boom
uh yeah i'm so i'm
there's so much i want to ask you about
that but hopefully i can do that when
it's coming out later this year
but i look forward to that yeah i cannot
wait
i mean um anyway i gotta go uh thank you
so much and have a fantastic day